let's start with a very hard to be
moving question for everyone on the
panel there this way we could give you a
newfound respect for ads pay people yes
I'd like to be better always respected
ants but that level of respect has
definitely increased throughout the
making of the movie it's important and
also that no ants were armed here's to
making a movie in anyway yeah they're so
many possible characters you know it was
phenomenally interesting between working
ants flying ants seeing all the
different characters was always a joy
the scenes when everyone take a brief
respite to look away at some of the ant
hills watch didn't work on the Bradys
yes in answer your question yes and try
to sound cute or anything but when even
last week I was standing by the sink and
some hands started walking toward the
coffee maker coffee and maybe earlier
time I would have just given them a
little now absolutely let them do what
they want to do and I stand back I can't
believe this
is questioned for repeating apologize
Phillips had quite attractive production
history with Edgar Wright involved and I
really like to tell those wonder what
that she could talk about these are
changes you made to get her a version
because he retains a scream like
credible in the film along with jet cars
yeah well I'll definitely start by
saying I think it's fair to say that
none of us would be here and there might
not even be an ant-man movie if it
weren't for Edgar and Jo and that should
absolutely go said you know the idea to
make a man heist movie structure was all
like her Joe the idea of Hank and Scott
like his mentor pupil again that was all
theirs and also the idea of a movie then
that all drives toward a third act where
the big battle between the good guy bad
guy takes place in a little girl's
bedroom that was always there from the
beginning and I I stand by in fact I
think that's genius I loved it when I
came on I really came on at the same
time that Adam and Paul were starting to
do rewrites on the draft and really it
was start taking what existed Adam and I
bonded over the fact that we were both
kids who grew up reading those comics
probably on twelve hours alone in my
bedroom reading comic books and same for
Adam so there were some elements that
had been in the comics that had not made
their way into the script that we wanted
to bring to it and then I think we also
wanted to serve to hate that heist
motivation act more sort of the
behind which in terms of via the visual
language of the movie and then also it
wasn't lost on me that you know hang him
in the comics is such a complicated
character and we had a very complicated
man who played neck everyone oh yeah
Michael you know this made an amazing
career out of playing you know character
sci-fi thing seriously with a lot of
gray area and really it was you know to
sort of just deepen that character and
the idea that always appealed to me from
the beginning that at the center of this
movie are two fathers and two daughters
and there was a lot of sort of emotional
how he to be mined from that so you know
Adam and Paul worked incredibly hard at
doing a rewrite cinema me reproduction
all continue to work with our production
writers Andrew barrer and a Ferrari so
really was an evolution but you know I
have to say I really get the spirit of
what Edgar Joe created from the
beginning is still very much a part of
the DNA of the movie sorry I didn't make
much reduced no I think you covered it
all my question is so when we're
creating personalities of these
characters in both nineteen
how much inspiration you actually draw
for the comics and even as far as the
personalities it said it's not for the
comics all the places he drew
inspiration the personalities well I you
know I I may be sort of the resident
pinyon I'm not sure like for you my god
like I
there's no comic book there I got called
Lewis so I it was somebody to Train
somebody that's actually lives in
Chicago he may or may not be a criminal
may or may not be in jail I can't stay
but his name is Pablo and actually I
have a little video he may or may not
have introduced himself to me that the
premiere is funny
Louise is a character from the first
time we see him some bad stuff has
happened to him in his life obviously
he's been in prison but you know
experiments left him smothered died his
father been deported he's still so
positive like a fan that's such a
beautiful quality and characters is
someone who in the face of all this
adversity is so positive and this guy
well you know I mean he does well I I
was not a common guy so I know anything
about this they were kind enough to send
me the spirit of a man along with a
leather-bound copy of two years of
ant-man comics which I'm digesting so we
can we talk so I two-dimensionally about
these four superhero movies when in
reality I was looking through these
comics my goodness Sears named him you
know very brilliant scientist warrior
created this incredible fact Factory in
building the pivot validation
technologies all of this wife was
involved with him lost her there was
more backstory for Hank in than any of
the so-called you know reality movies
that I might have done so I have a
pretty good clip reading blueprint to
follow what you read especially
I guess I was on the cusp of that
television audience so I did not go into
my room to read comics I watched The
Lone Ranger
I watched Hopalong and Cassidy
I watched Howdy Doody I was a television
black-and-white television theme back
there growing up that's how I remember
most of that other than that the books
more like you know Treasure Island Tom
Sawyer and that type I was very excited
about this opportunity with ink when
they came to me because I never have
done anything in this million you know
my entire career is contemporary based
not by choice just I guess I'm just
about characters but so all the printers
I've done except for one in 40 years as
a contemporary never did an effects
movie so you know I'm also a producer so
I was actually you know really curious
about how this whole thing went together
and got tremendous respect for Payton
you know and keeping all these pieces
together because as as we were filming
all together his actors there was
somebody else there the use of doing
special effects they were there were
stunts and there were also people just
doing ants point-of-use you know
which is pretty phenomenal on the
picture to be able to kind of juggle but
all of those pieces together was was
quite impressive so I enjoy the
experience also have a great
appreciation for actors who work with
great screen because there during
anything there and I'm not talking about
having to play make-believe
so again paint was very good and sort of
show you what it would look like so you
get that impression of you know that you
weren't really overacting and it would
be you know all that would be in place
and Paul was an anchor for the entire
picture he he maintained he was as
steady as they could be always made all
the other actors around him welcome he
gave himself a lot of good lies
yeah I had I think I was yeah English
characters you know kid-friendly kind of
stories and then you know now I still be
he knows everything about the wonderful
world and before I left to go to white
man he just says dad my avatar when he
pursued films lost mother about someone
I'd like to loved every single minute
fantastic
I've got a question from my ten-year-old
son from before if that's okay
he would like to know if you could be
any insect what would you be and why
would you be that insects which is a lot
nicer than the other one that my other
son had which was do any of your cast
members that he look like I'm gonna go
I'm gonna copy a ladybug is everybody
great mantis question report is for the
deacon tell us about the physical
aspects and the role and i hope you have
a better what he went through in order
to get such a good shape will make your
ask you perhaps I am I didn't do
anything fun for a year no or sugar I
worked out I basically made health and
fitness the focus of my day for a long
time I would work out with the trainer
I worked with a guy that was teaching
totally how to do flips and things like
that I was eating protein vegetables and
I was eating very specific times of the
day drinking alcohol
no I liked it actually I found that I
enjoyed having to focus I knew what was
gonna happen to be held accountable so
that made it a little easier but I had
never done anything like that before
to that extreme and and having this the
majority of my day built around that to
make Fitness something that I tried to
work in on the side what about my day
was was really kind of great I woke up
very early in the morning I felt really
good I have lots of energy and it helped
me also just get into the mindset of
this character and I figured if I'm if
I'm in really good shape I will feel
like less of an impostor and roll that's
take your shirt off today and wants to
see that just on your side by the way
this guy
here it's another question of the poll
as we yeah this will reach these who had
an XP is all the first generation of
model heroes does that happen the
pressure to you going as one of the new
breed of of yours I don't really think
in those terms I mean the pressure there
is only external pressures that you can
feel if you think about it for five
minutes I just like worry about what I'm
dealing with it at the moment and I want
to you know try and be believable in
this part focus on this I have no idea
what the future holds
I'm excited about it I'm interested in
playing this part in whatever way Marvel
sees fit I suppose but I don't I don't
think in those terms really
both month olds need if you get to where
they night on Susan and it's moving so
next time
well who's to say I wasn't wearing it
should I and I myself saw me coming on
missile heading right for for planet
Norfolk City star like easily they were
blurred what I was here listen after
seeing myself CGI the beginning of the
movie thirty years younger which was
incredible because it was that one of
the scenes with moogly lines and paints
that you'll get a kick out of this is
incomplete and half of it so the scene
the beginning of the movie and I had
these little dots all over activation
looking at it and halfway through the
picture the scene grew disappeared in
there I was thirty years ago
purchasing the thank you screen love the
film twofold I was what does your high
school movie signal a well this trend of
the universe coming forward survey on
and secondly you mentioned your level
comics renewing young at you tell me
some of your favorite stories much as
character base with actual stories yeah
well the first question I know if the
signals are trended Marmol I think
they've always done these sort of
subgenres and I think that's one of the
things that keeps the Marvel movies so
interesting I mean when you look at last
year that the American Winter Soldier
owes to service seventies political
thriller like a paranoid paranoid
thriller and guardians of the galaxy
which came out the same year it is crazy
gonzo space opera and our movie happens
to have the structure
I think that's one of these marbles
really done is you know sometimes we'll
talk to Kevin Feige said we don't make
superhero movies we made John remove
ease and I think it's been a very smart
thing in terms of the second thing I
always always in terms of the comics I
always loved the original Hank Pym you
know right around you 62 on the original
Avengers comics
I loved the relationship between Hank
and Janet the fact that they were an
amazing superhero duo but also the
romance between those two characters was
always fascinating and then also the
fact that Hank Pym there's a little bit
of schizophrenia and maybe a little bit
of an inferiority complex because in the
Avengers he was fighting alongside Thor
and Hulk and he always felt inadequate
and as we know an economist he changed
his identity a lot I found that
fascinating so those those early years
to me were great there's two questions
here for the second row the Marvel
movies always have quite a light touch
to them there's always a lot of comedy
but this in particular is extremely
funny is this something you guys are
going to continue with is that not gonna
stay lighter and I mean there were kids
well I'm hoping an audience's will
respond to this movie and if we're
fortunate enough to to be able to make
another ant-man movie I think there's a
lot of story left to tell with these
characters and I think there's also a
freedom at Marvel to kind of totally do
whatever we think is best what sources
story best so this one happens to be a
highly comedic heist movie and in terms
of its structure and tone I think
there's a portion of a man that will
always have a community component to it
but I like the idea that we could you
know an invent an entirely different
feel for a sequel that were fortunate
enough to be able to do and then to
Mary's white issues Sweden that is gonna
be all about silence Evangeline Lilly
who's not with us today
eight months pregnant
stayed to the very end question is
actually you should look very similar to
the previous questions but I would like
to know what things you'd like to
explore in town man 2 because obviously
the comments very rich of what common
themes and where would you like to take
your specific characters if there was
magic
let's start with Michael on the end over
there
just weighing it now so I like it but I
personally would like you know of course
when I hear in the morning do you want
to be some kind of superhero and I I've
had thoughts of where it goes things
that might happen but it's so embryonic
and they're no conversations with
anybody about it I don't know but like
Peyton said I you know opportunity would
say no but I think we get to the end of
this movie and there are a lot of
questions at the end of the movie about
what may or may not happen of these
characters I mean in terms of Scotland
he's become ant-man for the purposes of
this heist but what next you know
they're definitely some hints in the
movie and we also know that Paul is
gonna appear Scotland
or which is very exciting and if you
could hurt Paul's voice when he finished
his first day of shooting on the movie
were very excited I was well I saw by
her man in person and Captain America
it was weird was it made this whole
thing seem real in a way but I think
also you know I'll speak for Evangeline
who's not here but you know hopes are in
this movie is every bit as important as
as Scott's I mean she really in this
movie and particularly at the end of the
movie she's going to finally have her a
chance to be a hero as well and I think
it's exciting to imagine what might
happen with her and as far as as Hank
Kim you know the things that happen in
this movie
he'd been obsessed in the past with
exploring the quantum realm and trying
to figure out if he could save his his
wife and wasn't able to but there things
in half a team in the movie that might
reignite that obsession and it remains
to be seen if that's a good thing or a
bad thing
who knows maybe it's a good thing
having time for one last question the
children here in Sakura Captain America
Civil War was the scale
you